a friend of ours is lost on a parallel
earth and we're gonna go get him back a
parallel earth are you going to plan
it'll you know it's just a city of them
welcome to the jungle baby
who exactly is trot a giant telepathic
ape with her Aegis ships hairs my friend
I'm not gonna just abandon him
Indiana Jones much chance to visit
another dimension I wasn't gonna miss
that was I we're not going sightseeing
neither am i well damn speeds diverse
that's worst video game ever flash
gorilla City
hey guys what's up so we got a new
episode of the flash coming next week we
got to break this down and there's a
whole bunch of black flash zoom Easter
eggs in here too one of the reasons why
I love the flash more than a lot of the
other TV shows is just because they do
so much stuff from the comics in because
the flash has been such a popular comic
book character there's just so many more
stories for him to pull from so many
more characters so it's a lot richer but
there is a new round of the injustice
giveaway in just as two is coming out
real soon I'm giving away copies of the
game all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video be sure to click that Bell to
enable alerts so you don't miss anything
in it slightly related news I'll explain
at the end of the video but I'm gonna be
doing some in just as - on my game
channel which is separate from this
channel right here so I'll explain at
the end of the video so let's start with
the footage so we got a little bit more
Julian in this a little bit more Jesse
quick Wally West some of the people we
didn't see in the last trailer this is
gonna be so much fun it's Planet of the
Apes tell me this is planet of the apes
we're not going sightseeing the
gun like he's ready for business
that actually reminds me of that pre
sequence during episode 9 where they
told his backstory of how he found the
philosopher's stone the first time
it's been six months since I arrived
here in India though I have faith it's
out there the voice that once drove me
has waned and I feel my quest may be for
naught
this is it I can feel it I think we
should wait before we open it
it needs to be set free
and that's actually something really
important that I'll talk about at the
end of the video because the producers
were teasing some details that might let
us know House avatar makes it back into
our world even though Barry threw the
philosopher's stone into the speedforce
so the big thing here is that they're
teasing Grodd you get a better picture
of him on screen
who's Grodd big telepathic gorilla it's
a trap you see him walking through the
forest here we haven't been back in this
kind of setting since the season two
two-part episode and remember killer
frost is dead on this earth so Caitlin
is the only killer frost that we have
right now but you have to remember that
this is on a different part of the earth
this isn't just in the forest nearby
Central City of Earth - this is like way
off in the african continent's like a
way different part of the earth even
though it looks exactly the same that's
just because they film it in the forests
of Vancouver so anytime you film a
forest scene they're gonna look similar
no matter where it's supposed to be in
the context of the show I love the way
Barrie tries to downplay it - it's not
so much Planet of the Apes it's more
like a city of gorillas not quite as big
a deal anybody would fall to their chair
at the idea of that but Julian is
fascinated by all this stuff so he's
actually really excited to see this
because he hasn't ever been to earth 2
before but tying things to Caitlin here
she seems like she's kind of pairing off
with him just a little bit but the
really big thing that producers were
teasing for her character art the back
half of the season isn't continuing to
find a way to turn her powers off she
wants to get rid of them and because
Julian gave people powers with the
Philosopher's Stone she wonders maybe he
can take them away with it as well so
that's gonna be a separate video that
I'll post later because it's all about
killer frost betraying the team in the
name of getting rid of her powers you
know anytime someone on the team freaks
out goes rogue it completely goes
sideways in the most spectacular way so
speaking of going rogue jesse quick and
wally they're gonna be holding down the
fort on earth 1 while everybody goes to
earth 2 but they also tease that Jesse
quick is gonna be sticking around for
most of the rest of the season now I'm
not gonna talk about spoilers from
future episodes because there has been
behind the scenes stuff that's leaked so
if you want to talk about that please
use spoiler tags in the comments but the
produce
have just said based on the synopsis for
the second part of this two-part episode
is that she decides to stay so you can
speculate on what's going to be
happening with Jessie quick around
you're just gonna have a lot more
versions of the flash around which is
good because Savitt are is so much more
powerful than everyone so Wally Jessie
Barry all need to get faster but really
this two-part episode is all about a
self-contained gorilla grodd arc in the
lasting impact of that they've already
talked about what the second half is
going to be it's called a tack on
central city so you can just imagine
what's gonna be happening during that
episode so we can talk about that after
the episode drops next week there have
been a number of giant gorilla led
attacks on central city on Keystone City
the biggest ones were during the Wally
West era on Keystone City because that
was his city so even though they changed
the hunter zolomon origin story on the
TV show when he became zoom when he
became zoom in the comics it was because
he had been crippled after a giant
gorilla grodd attack given some of the
twist with the TV show you can imagine
the sequence of events that happened
next so this is the Wally West era in
the comics he's best friends with hunter
zolomon who's in this wheelchair he's a
detective kind of an Eddie Thawne type
character feeling very sorry for himself
but there's not a lot that Wally can do
so hunter zolomon knowing that he has
the powers of the flash in can time
travel pleads with a please go back in
time and change this in wally is just
like that is the worst idea ever so many
bad things would happen changing the
past is never a good idea and ironically
this is before flashpoint happens where
Barry goes back and saves his mother so
hunter zolomon knowing about the cosmic
treadmill at STAR Labs attempts to use
it himself to time-travel creates this
giant accident which gives him powers
and sort of phases him out with normal
time-space so instead of getting Speed
Force powers he sort of gets powers that
allow him to move in between the spaces
and time so theoretically he's faster
than the flash but just goes on this
rampage trying to make Wally a better
hero by making him experience all these
tragedies so is this really sad Archy
ends up going to prison
running into eobard thawne and that's
been
into another art but you have to
remember that our version of zoo now
became the black flash and we'll come
back to terrorize team flash and now
that it looks like we have Jesse quick
on the team it's gonna get that much
worse and remember both Jesse and wall-e
are fresh off the boat speedsters so
they're gonna make a lot of mistakes and
get their asses handed to them big time
we'll have to keep our eyes peeled to
see if they have any Easter eggs for
that I don't think that zoom is going to
come back the black flash will get
stored on the flesh and he technically
is zoom but he's kind of a different
persona now so I don't think there's
gonna be any zoom left in and when we
see him again but just because a
guerrilla attack of that magnitude on
the city is such a big deal
I don't think that everybody is gonna
escape unscathed somebody is gonna get
maimed big time so let me know in the
comments gorillas attack Central City
who do you think is going down not
necessarily dead but somebody is gonna
get their ass handed to them video game
channel though a lot of you been asking
me to do injustice to videos or just do
game videos in general do streams that's
all on my bonus Channel
Charlie's streams so if you don't know
what that is there's a link down in the
description there's links for my twitch
channel I will be doing some more game
stuff this year I'm working on hiring
some staff or at least one person to
help me out with videos so that I
actually have time to do stuff like that
and actually enjoy games so there will
probably be an injustice to video
posting on that channel later tonight
while you wait for that you can click
here for the Thor Doctor Strange
post-credit scene and you can click here
to learn about the rumor about the
Batman movie it's not true but I explain
what's going on there's more injustice
stuff going on thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you in the next video
you